so looks like you had a big chat with
your brother headed perceive your
somehow thinks there's a new something
I'll say where to see your video he
talks a lot of all words I thought this
was a physics Channel
yeah this is a pretty physics channel
hello everyone
Mayer morning this teacher well that's a
good question I mean you know titled
today is words and so guess ons here on
the other side of the desk
my guess is disputing whether that has
anything to do with physics buting I
think there are people who would dispute
oh then those people are wrong Oh blame
off of you a friend of mine yeah all
these people are wrong that's it yeah
it's easy no words are
is important well I'm saying they are
you know you simply can't do physics
without words and and I knew it's kind
of a boring subject for some of you
maybe you know maybe you say well bill I
thought you know this is a science
channel specifically a physics Channel
right and like you know we want to talk
about what energy mass and fields and I
don't know what else kind you know and
here you're filling us with words I mean
what the hell I mean what is all this
about and you know I found that at my
incursion into physics that 99% of the
problems are problems with language that
sounds like an overstatement no no no
under absolutely not it's an
understatement totally an understatement
because there's a totally uh
misapprehension or misconception that
you know physics specifically science in
general but physics in particular have
to do with what it has to do with you
know experiments making predictions
mathematics technology and so let
Compellent because I have a totally
different idea what Sciences then it
compels you to say well let's begin by
defining what science is then we can
move on to all these other subjects but
we absolutely need to define what's up
what science is so I define science as
rational explanations and people say
well that's your philosophy hold on yeah
they say that's that's your philosophy
that's your way of thinking that's not
what science is okay and please define
science for me in a concise unambiguous
manner so that I know exactly what you
mean by science okay and when you look
at the definitions of science that are
out there you know there are two pages
long the definition took definition you
know it's got all this
this wording and all the criteria
basically yes because that it's an
umbrella term that faulted in which
coverage every base yeah that's the
cover the disciplines of chemistry
biology physics everything we and and
excludes history economics that's not
science psychology or psychiatry social
sciences they can yeah but social
sciences is disregarded as you know
that's philosophy you know that's that's
not really science rightness and and so
we do need to get a hand on this word
science to begin with you know and I
think a good place to start is finding
what the word science means and it turns
out again they have two page long
definition and that already gives you an
idea that people don't professionals
we're not talking about the common
people out there you know the people who
never did any science or don't care
about science or whatever I'm talking
about the specialists the people
graduate the PhDs etc all these people
never found a need to define words
scientifically and therefore never
learned how to define what scientific as
two different things
what is science and what is the
scientific definition are two different
no no I agree I agree but this one I'm
getting it I'm saying that they never
did learn how to define words
scientifically and the clue there is
that if you want to define words
scientifically the shorter your you make
your definition the the easier it is to
defend the harder is to attack when you
put a lot of words there and ifs ands
and buts and commas and semicolons and I
don't know what else you know like the
Criminal Code in the United States I
know because I read it quite a bit of
that and you know they look at the just
an example right the mail fraud statute
it's it's a page long it's got all these
semicolons and and ifs ands and buts and
again the purpose of that whole law is
to cover every base if if they can
you know there there's been so many ways
that people got out of being punished
and so the Congress went in there and
said let's modify the law and they just
made this enormous monster that if you
read it you say you know who understands
this now we really need a lawyer to
understand just that paragraph no it's
the other way around that's what I'm
saying I'm saying that the more words
you put in there the more people can
start attacking you say well what about
this you know I don't agree with this
because it gives you an example and
destroys your your idea of that you know
it sounds like the opposite because if
you put like three words yeah and it's
like - babe you're not getting too
specific but that's the way the
foundation should be not not vague not
vague that's not the word the correct
word I think is umbrella in other words
you got to have anything that's read
done that can more or less like that in
other words what you want to do is like
you know I I give the example the word
object well I'm saying that you know
that which has shape and there's no way
you can produce an object to me that has
no shape you know what what object are
you gonna have put and so the word
object I identify it with shape because
shape is universal for all objects and
so Shiva has to be included in the
definition I don't care if you want to
later on we can fight about that you
know you can include massive nude volume
you can include that it moves you can do
anything you want but for sure for sure
you better include the word shape in
there because all objects in the
universe that God invented or that
mother nature evolved by any one
standard you think you have to have
shape right and and you'll need a
property that concepts don't have a
shape so it's like you know that's a
distinguishing food it's like a black or
a white and and that allows you to use
it consistently and that gives you a
good example why defining words is kind
of crucial especially when you're trying
to lay the foundations for a discipline
that's my point my point is you know you
go to a forum and you might want to
discuss physics or science or whatever
and you get into a debate with someone
and
start arguing before you argue please
define the foundations it's better to
dedicate your energies right to
discussing the foundations and
establishing the proper definitions
before you move on to saying well you
know the reason the earth moves around
the Sun is because it's sitting on what
space time and space time it gets warped
and that's what gravity is you know
before you get into all that into the
specifics defend the foundations because
that's where again 99.99 percent of the
problems lie and finishes a were an
example of the most recent time where
language was something you found on
Quora that language was the reason there
was a miscommunication or the personal
flat-out just well I'm working you know
as as I look at definition that
questions in kora you know I find that a
lot of people obviously people ask
qualitative type of question your if
you're a normal human being out there
who doesn't know anything about math
don't care about math you just want to
know you know where does a pencil drop
to the ground that kind of thing you
know it's it's a qualitative question
and and the answer they give you has
nothing to do with your qualitative
question they start going into equations
saying well you know this is what
quantum found out and they try to turn
it into a qualitative answer but they're
always there all quanta yeah these don't
know they they try to give you a
qualitative answer but they've found it
on quantitative concepts okay but yeah
that's what I'm saying so so what
happens what happens is you you know
you're these people want a qualitative
answer for qualitative answers you need
ordinary speech you don't need equations
you don't need numbers you don't need
functions and equations and variables
and numbers and so on not ordinary
scientific yeah yeah but it's a minimum
as a minimum I mean even if you don't
get into a scientific lens correct even
if you get into ordinary speech you know
you get a you know pygmy from the
jungles his language is limited he just
deals with bows and arrows and animals
and whatever how do you explain him you
know gravity or
well you gotta say something in in very
simple terms to him and you say well
this is the way it works how are you
gonna explain that to him well you're
gonna use language you're like assert me
you're not gonna use math or equations
with a big mean that's one issue the
other issue is that Mother Nature
doesn't understand all the abstract
concepts that we invented including all
the mathematical concepts well the
nation doesn't know what to is she
doesn't know what to is Mother Nature
doesn't know what a function is an
equation she doesn't deal with that
stuff she deals with object
you know asteroid hits moon she
understands that she don't know names
yeah and don't tell me about speed and
acceleration we don't think she doesn't
care about all that stuff so yeah good
old mother nature old mama like oh my
god so so my point here is we language
is important because you know again
first we have to define what science is
hopefully we don't lose Matt hopefully
we don't use an equation to define
science right yeah my point about that I
think you're wrong about that I don't
think we have to define Sciences no I
think we use law from that tangent too
often okay where that's more for
higher-level people they really want
like the whole picture ID okay realities
little question huh let's get to the big
picture what are what is science what
are we even doing here you know once you
deal with science enough you kind of hit
that question but all namin water knows
one question like why does the pen fall
to the ground they're about science or
the bigger picture okay just want one
answer but that is included within the
discipline the overall disciplined
umbrella discipline we call science yeah
but to explain something you don't
really need to know what science is no
you don't but I mean and again you're
right in that sense it's like if the
specialists want to get together out of
conference right we're gonna talk about
science
what is our discipline all the time yeah
let's let's define but let's begin by
Ukrainian science and not take for
granted that oh we know what science is
no no that's not true because we all
have different notions of what science
is that's yeah let's define science but
I think what you're doing with defining
science is you've kind of been in the
ring so much you're kind of way down the
rabbit hole in that so in that sense
where you kind of you've done enough
science to know okay hold on what have I
been doing all this time what is it
I've been with Alice in wonder yeah dr.
rabbit hole with her I've been with the
Queen of Hearts because you tackle all
the different facets of physics for
example now so when you've tackled
enough facets you go like like if
someone does enough comedy they ask okay
what is comedy not not by the third job
they're not having that big question
yeah he jokes you know you just don't
three jokes okay you just know for you
Joseph but if you're if you're a
comedian by train then you kind of go
deeper into the subject that's here what
is comedy and then you kind of ask her
the bigger questions about your own
discipline what is music what is
something that says you kind of hit that
wall where you've done it enough for you
okay what have I been doing these twenty
years I mean you you already know you
how to do it but you just kind of want
to know or put into words what are the
rules or what it what is this that I've
been doing but it comes back to what you
just said the example you just gave
you're a comedian and you're a
professional comedian stand-up comedian
or whatever after a while you start
asking more philosophical or more I
guess lower in the sense of fundamental
questions you know you try to get to the
bottom of your discipline your trade
whatever and you start asking well what
is comedy what makes people laugh or
whichever way you want to phrase the
question and you start being a little
philosophical about it start you're not
asking the right questions you know
maybe the person in the audience you
know you just listen to a jokes laughs
and leaves that's it right right but
just comes into physics there I mean you
could tell them what Sciences it is but
he probably will disagree until he
doesn't enough and finds that way right
yeah why you're right and and that's the
and you put it to a good issue there and
that's that the comedian is the guy you
got to listen to in general right or
from comedians that's where you're gonna
get the definition of comedy you know
the might be good these guys are into
that subject there's a specialist and
you're gonna get a you know an answer
from them you're gonna get a definition
from if you're gonna get a definition oh
you probably don't want to go just the
diction you say well what is comedy what
makes you laugh okay great you know I
know what it is but you know these guys
after a while after doing comedy for so
long it's their trade and they become
experts they can probably tell you in a
better
what science is yeah but comedy but well
I'm getting to the following and we can
do the same with science right we can
say okay let's ask a scientist but it
turns out that when you go out to the
scientist and they can't define the word
science in an objective way that it can
be used consistently because they have
all this wording they cover all the
bases and they say well you know
everything is science and you know
they're like God the word God means
everything then you got a problem with
that because it's just too broad on the
other hand you know when you say
rational explanations there's not much
to attack there yeah well you got to do
now is define rational and explanation
if that's even I mean you think those
are also self explanatory to find those
yeah okay right right like I think most
people understand what a rational
explanation is and I think I don't think
they do but maybe you can give me a
curveball like a test you give them a
question like is this a rational
explanation they might get 90% right
right the inefficiency I get mostly okay
I kind of know what science is and not
only that I think if you to a rational
individual thinking and being you know
even impartial guy right with a middle
education if you tell them look if you
move a concept that's irrational I think
you'll say yeah that that says I
wouldn't use the word irrational I just
call it like weird or like like a
criterium does not compute that word
somehow I was tainted was like crazy no
no but
and again remember we're referring to
the theory in other words my nation
if someone explains to me and says he'll
it moved love from A to B and you say
look that's irrational because you're
moving a concept I think most people
will agree and say well yeah yeah I
think you're right you know I mean I'm
not gonna argue against that so so
that's my point
you got to define first the word science
and in fact you find those rational
explanations you gotta find rational
explanations so that people understand
what you're referring to but that's not
what these people do because again
they've never learned to define word
scientifically they never paid attention
to words
they just take the word out of the
dictionary whatever they learned in high
school which is the words they feed you
at first which is from ordinary speeds
from the ordinary dictionary and it just
use these words without paying attention
to them they say look I don't want to
deal with grammar I want to deal with
equations with variables with numbers
and you know when this guy come you know
me comes over and says well you know
what do you mean by us what is a point
on it yeah what do you mean what do I
mean by who carry you know you know they
don't realize the importance because
they're satisfied with the notion of the
word not the definition just the notion
like you might say you know love we both
have the relatively ballpark same notion
but it's still kind of a Venn diagram I
have things outside of your notion of
love your the protocol blows yeah but
it's like or to take whatever justice we
both have our own forms of just sense of
justice whatever you want to call it but
that's more like vendek we're not
completely overlapping so when I say
justice it's like some the notion is
there you kind of know what I'm talking
about Billie if I go into some specific
tangent put them against the ropes not
not putting my throws but if I try to
explain something by using the word
justice and I use it in a way that is is
goes off on this really specific tangent
of justice that isn't in your Venn
diagram in your circle now I got a
problem because now I'm explaining
something with my theory that you don't
understand because you don't use the
word justice in the same way yeah that's
why you have to that's why notions of
words don't suffice in science because
in science if you're using notions now I
mean the science we're trying to get to
the nitty-gritty and the nitty-gritty is
usually where a notion of notions fall
apart the application at the singularity
they say that's where everything falls
apart in physics they say physics breaks
down at the singularity and you know we
try to get to the singularity but that
that's when they say well phrase it
breaks down and we adjourn and we call
another meeting some other day but back
back to the physics professionals right
so we got physics professionals yeah I
kind of went down the rabbit hole on
most of these subjects of magnetism
light gravity maybe just one enough to
kind of fix their web of information or
never
of knowledge whatever you want to call
it but we're talking about definitions
and we understand why definitions make a
maker break the profession of physicists
uh-huh but when we're talking about
laymen why's is so important like does
the layman have to know exactly what
what object means well if you again it
goes by steps goes by steps if you say
look science is divided into physics and
philosophy physics studies objects
causes and mechanisms then at some point
someone's gonna say oh it's studies
objects that's a key word so what is an
object obviously there's gonna that
definition is gonna come up as a
question and should come up as a
question you should know what an object
is if physics is if the bread and butter
is the building block of physics if
everything you're gonna do is based on
objects and you need an object to do
physics just imagine no objects in the
universe there's nothing there what
physic what event is happening what what
are you gonna explain what what is
happening what are you gonna be doing
what are you gonna be doing in the lab
what do you be moving there's nothing to
move obviously physics is done with
objects and then the next question is
okay so what is an object and obviously
you get a you get a make the ordinary
human out there both intelligent and non
intelligent both educated non-injury you
got to make them understand you can't do
physics without without objects and then
the next you know invariable question is
what is an object and you know the
mathematician will say well you know I
ever thought about that I guess it's
volume I guess it's mass I guess if
that's which moves and you say notice
that which has shape and you know that
destroys like 120 percent of his
theories because you know all of them
are based on concepts you know they
transfer energy they move a mass they
carry a force they dilate time and you
said well you know you can't do that not
in physics that's okay it's a metaphor
you know but you can't use that to
explain a physical phenomenon and as
where the fist fight starts because the
guy says oh you're you're harping on
semantics no I'm
to the heart what your theory says your
theory says that you warp time and he
said well that's not what I really said
or what I really meant okay what did you
really mean and so the guy has to go in
there and say well you know you take
space and you unite it with time what do
you mean you mean it with time time is a
concept so you're not talking about
objects you're doing physics without
objects and that's where you start you
know that's when the guy abandons says
well you're not doing science and I'm
gonna talk with you anymore you know
you're pushing him against the corner
because the guy can't answer in a
qualitative sense he cannot give you a
physical interpretation with concepts
because concepts is the opposite of
physics a physical you know you had
abstractions and you have physical and
they're doing abstractions that's the
issue we're talking about physics right
and someone explaining something yeah
let's take a mathematical physicist he
wants to explain something to let's say
a kid or let's say a teenager so that he
doesn't have to patronize the person
right uses math or whatever okay but
when you use an undefined word or a
mystifying word or a like notion of
blurry definition yeah
they forget about the listener for a
moment like we talked about a lot about
the communication value of physics but
forget about the listener for a moment
when he's explaining something right I
mean he uses a mystifying word or an
undefined word can we say the explainer
even understands what he's explaining no
I don't think they do they cannot
because in order to understand fit you
have to visualize you have to watch that
movie inside your mind and you and you
watch that movie through your ears
unless he shows you a movie right but
he's explaining this
yeah you're it's coming into your ears
and you're trying to visualize what this
guy is saying what are you gonna
visualize for energy what are you gonna
visualize for force what are you gonna
visualize for time nothing did that mean
I getting mean that's that's the
listener I'm talking about the person
who's explaining he's listening to his
own speech first but but before he goes
there he already you know at the school
and he's already got in his mind but
then the question is what did you
visualize when the professor told you to
memorize for the test on
Friday you know that space-time has
worked what did you visualize well I
visualized of canvas is there a canvas
well no that's that's what we use to
simulate to pictorially represent what
we really mean as and he goes into his
bath right he says look the equation
here says listen this and that so he's
given a physical interpretation to his
equation but what does he use he uses a
canvas and he's bringing that in and let
me give you another example which is
comes all the way from Maxwell you know
Maxwell essentially based on a lot of
the research that was done up till the
1850s mint mid 19th century people like
Faraday and so on or said you know he
came up and he said okay I finally
figured it out with these equations I
can show that light is an
electromagnetic wave and travels at
300,000 kilometers per second when your
head when he said right said that what
yeah and so the question is what was he
visualizing and if you go into his books
which I read by the way you go to this
book he has a definition for the for the
way for the electromagnetic wave
specifically for the word field because
the electromagnetic wave is electric
field magnetic field right it may go
orthogonal e to each other so now we're
talking about orthogonal
you better be start visualizing
something something yeah yeah you can't
have a love you parallel to intelligence
yeah I mean that may be in in philosophy
maybe I don't know in some kind of
abstract metaphorical way but or or
maybe surrealistic for Dali and all
these other you know even they have to
draw something I guess even if they draw
your conscience or whatever they got to
put something on the board is this a
conscious or whatever these shows got to
represent what you got here in your head
but you know Maxwell you know he said
okay electric and magnetic fields okay
they're orthogonal okay so what did he
draw well he you know and he goes in
there and he says you know
we think there is some kind of ether
made of particles and he's kind of
postulating and he's making that
assumption that su position what else
could he do
eighteen fifty you know 1960 he really
wrote his book in 1864 published in 1865
and he said you know this is the best we
have today that's right and and yeah and
it is fine that is why because he was
concerned more about describing it
mathematically than about visualizing
but he makes a very important point he
says look
Faraday Michael Faraday who was his
senior he was like 40 years older I mean
Faraday was like 40 40 or 50 years old
when Maxwell was born
okay so there was a big difference in
their ages but you know man
Faraday had out on all these experiments
he made all these this dissertations at
the Royal Institution you know called
philosophical philosophical magazines
and so on and and so he spoke a lot
about his experiments and then finally
Maxwell said look you know I don't deal
with experiments what I do is math and
he took all of Faraday's observations he
put it into math for me he says okay and
remember also at the time we had people
like fizeau and arm and full cult in
France they measured the speed of light
so they had all these little bits of
pieces of data they say okay we have
light travels at 300,000 kilometers per
second here this guy says the magnetic
field generates the electric field the
other guy says the electric field
generates a magnetic field so Maxwell
can't around it all that I'll put it
together he says okay I think I figured
it out look this is the equation
explains that life is a transverse wave
already determined by my light light is
a transverse wave already figured out by
was the name French guy sometimes I
forget his name gusta prayer
now okay so he already had figured out
in the 1820s you know that light is some
kind of transverse wave he used it to
explain polarization so you know Maxwell
took all these bits and pieces he put it
together you came up with his four
famous equations and he said okay I
think I know what I'm talking about I
can describe this thing he didn't call
it a thing right he says this
abstraction which i think is the motion
of the ether which was a concept that
already existed even longer like three
hundred years and he says I can describe
the motion of this ether with these
equations but he he and see me he put it
in his I think it wasn't either in his
pre-fit yeah it was in his preface and
he says you know people think that it's
some kind of physical object there that
is not comparable to what we have in our
ordinary world of macro world
it's depend a thing out there but we
can't place our finger on it we'll
called ether but I'm not gonna talk
about the ether I'm gonna describe its
motion he said that so so they got into
this abstraction from there they
continued to build all the way to today
you know in the electromagnetic wave and
a wave eventually turned into the
particle you know collapses into the
particle the particle travels as a wave
and then collapses when it is something
into a particle and that's what we have
today but it all comes from those days
and and against all abstract because
they never define the object that is in
there or more precisely saying when they
say that word when they utter it it
doesn't give you anything to put in your
movie correct and so these people veered
off into abstractions and forget about
the definitions what are we talking
about let me give an example here yeah
and it's in the case of what we have
today in quantum mechanics if you look
at the slit experiment they always start
with a way they say look like it's so so
strange because they say a photon right
you heard of the word photon what do you
think of you know a little ball some
kind of tiny ball that's not what it is
they start out they saying look a photon
is an is a wave
what what do you mean a vote I cut it in
the standard model shows up as a little
dot as a little part of a little ball
and now you're telling me it's an
extended object called the wave okay
that's how they start they'd say though
we send waves why because with waves
weakening explain interference
constructive and destructive what
happened they show it with water waves
they say look you throw two stones in
the water at the same time right or just
shake the water in two places and the
waves the ripples come out and they
interfere with each other where the
ripples are in sync you get constructive
interference when they're where they're
out of sync you get destructive
interference so that's the first thing
they explained but now there you go to
the next step and they say as soon as it
touches something it automatically
collapses as they say the wave collapse
right it collapses into a particle it
turns into you know there's this spread
out thing somehow gets concentrated
suddenly surreptitiously
and turns into a little particle on dot
and now they explained to us with a dot
and so they've they've done all these
experiments they also treat the electron
as a dot and so now they say well let's
let's do the experiment the photons do
it with electrons and let's see what we
get and they try covering one of the
slits they tried observing one of the
slit and they say we every time we do
something like that we interfere with a
particle and you say okay so you because
you you can you know by looking at you
through photons at it and you move the
particle out of the way or whatever you
know you interfered with it so you can't
look at the experiment because every
time you look you affect the experiment
okay fine so what happens the particle
so called particle goes through both
slits and they have to do this because
the particle has to recombine though the
wave notion of the particle if you can
possibly imagine such a thing the wave
notion of the particle now the wave has
to interfere in order to produce the
interference fringes exactly the
particles at to place notice at three
places at once it also hits the center
of the slit so the particle 1 particle
just kenra is at 3 places at once for
this America be of many
places but at least in three it goes
through one straight the other one and
the third one of this particle hits the
center it's not like the car the
particle splits in three it's the same
particle at three locations let's make
that clear because now the particle has
to come back and interfere with itself
in order to produce the constructive and
destructive fringes bands you know on
the on the wall and you know one
particle in three places yeah okay so
that's the first problem then what
happens it turns out okay you say the
particle and they say well the particle
is not a particle what do you mean I
thought you define particle as a
corpuscle no that's not what it is it's
a field what do you mean it's a field
yeah particle is really a field it's
everywhere at once there's this field
that extends from the party go out to
the edge of the universe so you got a
spiderweb going through the slit how do
you do that that that is magic I mean if
it's a discrete particle you can
conceive and you can imagine you can
visualize you to make a movie of it
going through the slit but if this is a
spiderweb that extends to the edge of
the universe how do you get it through
the slit yeah well the center what
happened to the poor spider that was
earlier is there uh you know standing on
the spider where does he go he gets he
gets uh what is it siphoned outta there
he goes
he gets uh this is the issue the issue
is that these people convert the words
again we're talking about the physical
interpretations they keep going back and
forth particle what is a part of us a
field what is the field well it's a
really a probability distribution what
is the probability
what's a wavefunction and they just keep
giving you the runaround you say well
come on I thought a particle was a
particle you know expect a bust we all
understand that corpuscle sake or pause
don't say particle if particle means
something special in your in your
religion if you're gonna talk to the
pygmy say look a quart plus or stone
nina understands that you say you know i
throw stone through a slit he'll
understand it perfectly well but if you
say well that wasn't really a stone I
just used that as a simile or as a or as
a figure of speech
so what is a the part
well it's really a spider's web that
extends all the way to the edge of the
universe the guy's gonna look at you and
go saying you're crazy what do you mean
how did you get it through the slit how
did you get all those little tangled
little threads through the slit you said
an interesting thing with the runner on
thing we're with a definition right yeah
if can is it fees I mean I think it's
possible can I give a definition to
something that lead that leaves me an
out or like one word in the definition
or a phrase in the definition somehow
leads to further definitions with which
I can patchwork you know if I if I if
for the example the word particle right
because we argue about definition yeah
use the word particle but I define it in
such a way that it's kind of ambiguous
enough that I can use it this way here
and this way yeah can we make it not
ambiguous at all
right biggest enough what do you mean by
that means that I can have a loophole
through which to escape more tangent
well this is the problem they do have
all these loopholes and that's the
problem because you say particle but
particle is not a particle so funk it's
a field so what is a field where it's
away from what is a wavefunction it's
you know probability distribution would
you know they just keep giving you the
runaround and and so question you never
get to the point the point is that you
know all they have is just all the the
series of concepts and they're not
really talking about a physical object
so back to square one you say what is
science about what is physics about
those physics require an object if it
requires an object don't give me concept
don't tell me a particle is a wave fun
real quick to that you don't worry it
goes back to my idea you don't have to
know physics is if I just want to know
how gravity works right right and they
come with particles but they're not
actually particles they're concepts of
fields you know they're just the right
isn't an object then I go wait hold on
but then what what do I imagine in my
head what's the thing that's actually
pulling me towards the the earth you
can't just give me a probability area an
area where where I I'm heavier here
heavier there yeah okay that that tells
me it's something that describes what
distance from the center I'm how heavy
description
but it doesn't tell me why does it why
is there a tox planation ya know why
isn't there at all part is but that's
that's why I'm saying that physics you
have to make a movie see if you make a
move in you put stones there's no
there's no ambiguity you say okay the
stone went through the slit in the
double slip for example or in
polarization the stone went through the
slab and then when he turned it around
somehow you know it blocked the stone
okay fine if you do with stones
everybody understands you're the pygmy
will understand the the Guyana
University well everybody will
understand but if you at the end of your
comp you know this at least you'll
understand your theory now it doesn't
mean that you will agree it just means
that they'll understand what you're
trying to propose but if at the end of
your dissertation show by the way the
stone is not a stone oh can you give you
a presentation again that's what that's
why that's why you have to do it at the
beginning when I show you the whole
movie and by the way we have is dead at
the end that's the whole movie again
because now has a completely different
meaning yeah and this is this is the
issue the issue is you know in science
that's why you gotta work in an
organized manner hopefully the guy up
there you know giving the presentation
he says let me start out with the
objects and the definition so this isn't
the objects I'm gonna deal with I'm
gonna call him XY and Z and he served
the definitions I'm gonna call them ABC
fine we got all that now we can follow
his presentation but if he says look I'm
gonna show you a movie of Mayan theory
and he starts showing his movie shows
stones moving around and at the end of
the story you said did you understand my
theory said yeah I understood it
perfectly I don't agree because I
there's a lot of questions I've got with
it and one of the questions is you know
what are those stones that when oh
they're not really stones yeah you can't
change it later on and and now you say
okay let's start over you were throwing
stone through the slit now you're saying
they're not stones so what are they
well there are spiderwebs they extend
all the way to the edge of the universe
because that's what a field is you know
it's it's a radial system of
use of magnitudes that's all there is a
field and you get the definition from
the two guys Faraday who invented the
word and Maxwell who propagated it he
disseminated this word and so these guys
are the ones who really pushed the word
field and today it's become a monster
because nobody knows what a field is in
other words and what I mean by that is
yeah they knew what a meat-filled is
it's a region of space around an object
that has all these values and you say
well a region of space with values is
what went through the slit is that what
you're trying and so the guy said well
you need to take the college course to
understand what no you think the first
to be able to explain this to your whole
job is to bring this down to
understandable oh you can't you get I
mean their whole job is to make it
understandable to the layman if they at
any point they say oh you have to go to
the University no what what what do I
need you for
Einstein said you know you can't explain
it to a barmaid then you don't know it
well enough nothing right and Fineman
says if you can't explain it to a
ten-year-old
well something similar like you know
then then you don't know it well enough
yeah it's worse if you can't explain it
to a ten-year-old you you're not doing
your job yeah yeah that's what holds the
whole job is to figure out the secrets
of the universe and then bring back that
information I just leave it there for
you to go pick it up at the University
to the irony the iron is that Feynman
was asked okay how does a magnet work
with all this rigmarole twenty minutes
talking about nonsense and he couldn't
explain it to a ten-year-old so I guess
he didn't know well enough because he
said you know you depends on who you
want to talk if you want to if you
really want to get into DBA take a
college but then what do we need them
for that sort of get what do you need a
the physicist their whole job is to go
go and come back with the information
give it to everyone else but what they
do is they go go pick up the information
get like horrified by what they saw or
something come back traumatized and they
say you have to go by yourself
you got horrified by what they don't
understand yeah nobody I mean
this is simple here's a here's a stick
right and you let go of it and it falls
to the ground
I mean how complicated how complicated
is this system we're talking about a
stick
we're talking about the earth I guess
because it falls to the ground to the
center of the earth we say the system is
very simple if you don't like that you
got two magnets you know what attracts
the other house here it is two magnets
you know that's the entire system I mean
do you need to go to a university to
understand the mechanism how this
attracts that
yeah I mean we're not talking about
remember this is a very simple system
two pieces of metal one attracts the
other why do you need to go to the
University learn calculus and all that
to explain what causes the physical
mechanism of attraction because we're
not interested in a cause an interesting
but that's my point my point I just want
the minute to explain this and I'm done
with them I won't ask him any more
questions
how this attracts that and don't give me
all this nonsense about you know oh you
need to take a college course and
understand all this calculus into what
all I want to know is how this piece of
metal attracts that one that's all I
want to please don't give me any more
than you know BS question what is the
job I don't know if you had to say
assuming someone more paying you yeah
they are we're doing patreon yeah what
is your job to explain that's what I
think right right to exploit might go to
a physicist right yeah they should be
able to explain and not tell me oh you
have to find out by yourself if I go to
you and I say boss how does a magnet
work yeah I don't you don't say figure
it out there's nothing I don't need you
or take a college course and you'll know
but then it's like your ear
it should have been you you didn't do
your job physics isn't it's twofold this
is one figuring it out for yourself yeah
but two I think the real important part
of a physicist is really explaining it
to others I mean it's nice to know for
yourself but I think the real fun in
physics is really spreading and that is
what I say science is you explain and
usually I mean first you gotta explain
to yourself to understand it yourself
but eventually you know the purpose of
that is not to be on an island just say
oh that's nice if we just good to you
know for your own benefit but you want
to share that and say look I want to
share a theory with you how I think this
works or how that works that's the point
you to explain to someone else that's
why we do conferences that's why people
get together and discuss science to
exchange ideas and say well how does
this universe work how does our earth or
how to do everyday things work you want
to be able to explain if you can't
explain it then what is the point of
physics if you're just gonna say well
I'm just gonna describe I can't worry
what's the point of view why are you
even at the discussion if you're not
gonna help everyone explain anything and
we're just gonna come and just keep
describing describing or let's say
you're just let's say you have a
conference write a pl and we're all
trying to figure out how magnets work
and there's one guy this is just
literally just spouting gibberish that
no one can understand why is even at the
table and there's another issue involved
with that question that's you know you
have all these people saying that math
and science because they the quake
mathematical physics with science here
let me put a little thing that I've got
here where is it here it is here you
have professor Donaldson Aki's emeritus
professor at a university in
Pennsylvania and you have Nobel Prize
Steven Weinberg this is what they say
first guy says science doesn't explain
science describes he's referring to
mathematics really because that's all
that mathematics can do and then Steven
Weber was also asked you know how about
the explanations etc about mathematics
he was asked he said well I don't think
mathematics can ever be regarded as an
explanation in itself of anything
and this is not always well understood
so so now keep that in mind for a second
so so if that's the case you wonder why
are these people always trying to give a
physical interpretation I
I mean if math only describes and that's
all that mathematics can do in equations
just the description why did they move
that extra step and say this is the
physical interpretation this is the
explanation this is the mechanism and
they give you a nonsense mechanism you
know where they move energy or they
dilate time or whatever you say well
hold it that's irrational and they say
well yeah perceived because you got to
take a math course to understand it no
no I don't need a math you already did
the math you showed me the equation
that's fine but now you're giving a
physical interpretation to that equation
why do I have to take for the physical
interpretation part for the qualitative
part why do I have to take a course at
the University this is something you can
explain in qualitative terms ordinary
speech ordinary language you know you
should be able to more or less maybe you
know maybe you need some special terms
there but in general you should be able
to make a movie of your of your physical
interpretation I watch the movie and
I'll understand it and so the question
is why do they go that extra mile try to
explain something when math has no such
power no such authority that's all we
really care about deep down you know the
common man yeah no no even physicists I
think I mean mathematical physicists are
huh I think they really do or at least
at some point they really did want to
know how does the universe work yeah I
think they still do most of them just
kind of at some point maybe just get
like disenchanted because the best
frustrated yeah because the best that
we've got we excluding you is what they
get so they get that it's a ok if this
is all we got then this must be what it
is so you just kind of stopped searching
yeah but see these people have gone to
college and from generation to
generation
since the 1920s at least since the least
official a conference they said we can't
understand the universe don't try to
explain it will never end
stand the universe all we can do is
describe it and there's a couple
statements from Niels Bohr especially
who was the Guru at the time and he said
something of you know as I said many
many statements all to the effect that
no one understands quantum mechanics
don't try to explain with it all we can
do is describe it all we can do is
quantify it using you know mother
nature's uh
mathematics which mother nature doesn't
understand and don't try to understand
really how this universe works because
we'll never understand and so people
have gone to college learn this by rote
and they just keep repeating yeah we'll
never understand who can understand but
again it's all because they use the
particle ha ha no it's not because the
particle oh that's an important part is
really a tradition what is the tradition
why why do why does father pass down a
tradition to his son because it's worked
for X amount of years I mean you just
said it physics has been this way since
1900s Thank You Anita it's been this old
right and we've had no process is what
everyone has been saying for a hundred
years
yeah almost two years off X Imani
geniuses have tackled this problem who
are you to question it's really a huge
tradition with authority or is more than
authority it is tradition kind of trumps
Authority in that sense because
tradition and it is a collective
Authority its authority past authority
over authority Authority in 1920 stated
the authority in 1930 said 1914 a
generational generation by generation
everyone is saying is why question it on
top of the fact that you needed for your
test or you don't pass you don't
graduate you don't become a physicist
tonight and physicist how are you gonna
not not explain things to people outside
yeah and so again you know it's it's one
of those things that you do need to
define words you need to be absolutely
certain of what rigorously right you
need to be absolutely certain of what
you're talking about what you're
referring to especially if you're gonna
make a movie imagine you're the director
of movie you better know what the
objects are in that movie because that's
gonna appear in each one of your frames
and you better separate the ABS
from the concepts if you're gonna talk
about motion for example orbit or
anything of that nature where there's
you know that something dynamic going on
that's fine you can talk about that but
you know you in each frame you're gonna
have to put some physical object what
are you gonna put in there you put
energy because it's it's really the
objects that we don't really have a
problem with imagining it's when you
talk because we really aren't so what
I've never trying to explain an object
right we're always trying to explain a
phenomenon a clock explained an object
actually point to exactly but in a way
we're not explaining I wanna I wanna
explain the phenomenon of magnetism or
the phenomenon of gravity it's really a
concept in a way that we're trying to
explain yeah because it's the mechanism
it's a it's a happen the mechanism
itself exactly which is so weird energy
energy is a mechanism so if you throw
much objects at me no problem I can just
make a collection of that in my in a
room in my head I just make it head in
my head I just imagine everything you
say but when you start throwing concepts
and at me now it's tricky because it's
actually with a concept you're giving me
a recipe to eat to how to move these
objects or how they interact with each
other it's already an object in motion
by the way yeah concept already is an
object in motion yeah but that's so
saying if you take any concept right
you're throwing love or justice and
swimming swimming anything yeah now
you're you're taking one of these
objects in my head and you're gonna move
it in a specific way you're giving me
instructions on how to move with any one
specific object with every concept you
throw at me
yeah giving me instructions to move one
of these yeah so the objects I don't
think people have a problem with I mean
I know mathematical physicists get that
wrong they can you know they think they
use concepts as objects but I think the
normal plan from the normal person
anyone just wants to know how do I move
these objects so that this phenomenon
makes sense and when you start throwing
concepts that you haven't regular
rigorously defined not you're giving
them vague instructions to move these
objects you can have a ball yeah I don't
need that there's there's a second issue
in that said if you have ten people in
the audience they're all
understand something different because
everybody's gonna imagine something
according to their upbringing because
you haven't specified it to them you
know if you if you put a wrong and
everybody sees the rock I guess
everybody imagines the same thing
because that's what they're visualizing
but if you say a concept such as energy
well this guy imagines a spirit because
he's a religious person he says I know
what he's talking about he's talking
about an angel or a spirit or a ghost
the other guy thinks it's a cloud of
smoke of some of some kind the other one
thinks of an equation said well now that
means an equation so everybody's gonna
understand something different because
there is nothing to visualize with that
word in a way is can it be said okay we
got objects right I'll just a shape in
your head yeah I just just talking about
explaining theory your theory explain it
with objects we got objects and concepts
you know we don't have anything else any
other words so with objects I think is
easily you say ball I just imagine what
you point to yeah but then with concepts
is it fair to say that concepts are
essentially instructions instructions
for the objects in my head if you use
any concept any conceptual word concept
word it's more instruction what do you
expect what do you mean it's wrong you
say swimming right yeah a dog is
swimming okay imagine swimming and the
instruction sorry I imagine dog right
yeah and the instruction is swimming
because swimming is a concept so by
default it's gonna be an instruction
that you attach to an object in my head
to move it how do I move this dog he's
swimming okay now I have to imagine the
water I mean obviously you probably sit
down - so now you move the dog in a
swimming fashion okay and I think you
can the same could be said for all
concepts anytime you define a concept
now it's kind of like you're giving an
instruction at least the the the action
concepts like the verbs I mean you give
you instructions on how to visualize
yeah yeah how do visually more how to
move yeah yeah if I you can say ball
right ball okay guys I got still ball in
my head but easily a bouncing ball now
you've given an instruction in my head
like how do I move this ball in my head
if I say flying versus running baby
where's this even swim any of that or
location now okay now you
look at the distance between two balls
yeah I'm not looking at the balls and
I'm looking at the distance between them
or yeah yeah so it's like it kind of
tells you where to look in your head or
what to focus on it's kind of like an
instruction okay that's one way of
looking at it I'd have to look at that
that's where the problem comes in with
with undefined words because an
undefined word is a vague just
instruction yeah what I see with
undefined words is that first people
imagined something different you know
everyone understands something different
second if you define the word but you
use too many words well with so many
trying to cover all the bases like
saying and if an and and but and so on
semicolon here comma there you know then
first it's easier to tear down because
the more factors you include the easier
it is to say well how about this one how
about this exception here you know
that's one issue the other issue is that
if it's lengthy it means that you know
you really haven't pinpointed the
concept officially if it's a fundamental
constants a good point
how DMP wordy how do you visualize a
concept you can have there's no visual
that visualize up to know you're on oh
because I'm wrong yeah you're wrong okay
I'm not rationally wrong here because oh
you say later that ones are falling
right you can't you can't explain why
you can explain anything without a
concept let's start there correct yeah
that's what I'm saying but you can't do
anything without it you can't swim yeah
obviously but but you can have objects
in your head visualize yeah that's what
I mean with how do you visualize the
constants obviously there's no sheet of
falling right yeah you have to put it
shmo what are you visualizing when you
use a card so when I say what's a good
concept or word exists yeah but it's a
static concept yes you picked the wrong
one
okay give me a swimming or flying you
know think let's take flying
yeah thanks better to concept if you
take flying and you talk about a nice
plane yeah you need to put an airplane
you need it but illegal motion you need
you need a ball you need an ego
need-a airplane something out there a
balloon to talk about flying you know
you need to put an object and then yes
you need to show it instructions I don't
know about the word instructs I'll have
to think about it but yeah you're
essentially putting a movie of it but
then you would have to define the word
flying so that you distinguish it from
swimming or jumping or any or running or
any other concept of dynamic content
orbit you would have to distinguish
those so that you can use them
consistently you know jumping is not the
same thing as running which is not same
thing as flying or swimming then people
can say okay this is black this is why
this is red this is blue they can
separate these colors in their minds at
least you know how these words are being
defined but if you don't make that
distinction and you simply take the
words of ordinary speech with which may
not you know like let's assume you go to
the dictionary and say flying it's a
type of motion okay so it's jumping so
are they different well now you gotta go
a little step deeper and say well this
one is this and this one is that you get
it you got to separate those two words
in some way if you're gonna define them
okay but back to the instruction thing
you know it's static cons will you call
static concepts don't exist right yeah
that way says location that's how you
define yeah so you have so when someone
says exists
you give me instructions on what are you
looking at you're looking at the object
the property is its location essentially
you give them instructions okay when you
say God exists what do you what in your
head
where's the camera going to make sure
something exists and one way to get to
that point is making a movie because
then you say this is what's in my mind
yeah that's that's that's like putting
one's in your head outwards and it also
reads and it also reduces the crowds
interpretation because if you just give
words let's say you don't have a movie
right you just tell the story well
people might interpret it with things
differently yeah if you make a movie
everybody sees the same frames they
might still have different ideas but it
gets some more uniform that's a lot
amazing yeah it kind of tunnels them you
know sense them through the thigh
everybody more or less understands the
same
you want to leave no room for
interpretation in physics is the exact
opposite of poetry and poetry you kind
of want to make it a lot of room for
interpretation want to make it so that
everyone understood the exact same
that's a good analogy poetry you wanna
you wanna leave room for interpretation
yeah I call it mislead you wanna mislead
write poetry you want to mislead because
the purpose of Portrush to get you to
fantasize yes to say something but mean
something else or mean something you say
one thing but mean but imply that you
meant something else so it's up to the
other person to figure out okay what did
he mean so maybe they start going off on
tangents talking about this and the
other guy says I don't even that is
right like the Bible you guys interpret
in so many ways yeah however way you
mean it essentially and that's really
thing and it's written in the Bible so
in a way it being written doesn't it
doesn't equate to a movie if the Bobby
Bible is a movie now it gives way well
as now there's no interpreter hold it
hold it yeah let's let's that's an
interesting point because now the Bible
let's say you take the I don't know
scene of creation or God creating man
right and you know as long as you exceed
it and in the book you say okay so God
created the universe he created the the
birds and the bees and everything else
then you created Adam and Eve fine and
now you say well you know you trying to
imagine how did he do that just give me
a match well yeah no but my point is you
know people say try to imagine what
happened some some imagining in a vague
way others we take it literally etc now
you put it on the screen now you bring
God in there you know you say okay Joey
you're gonna do the part of God
yeah and so you dress them up with a
beard oh no magic quantity okay now
you're gonna be God you have to stand
some right now you know this is location
you film s and you see this guy making
Adam and Eve and with Anthony what
happened yes and now the details no no
but there's something else you know
maybe they're all the same size God in
Adam and Eve or maybe you got to make
them like a giant you know God is
so now you said well he's got a giant or
was he experimental in different ways is
no magic wand all this like you say a
picture's worth a thousand words and
movies worth a thousand pictures so if
you make a movie I know that was a big
day you got a movie of something right
now you cut off so many interpretations
but by making him white by giving him
the beaker by giving him a blonde but
you're gonna sleep got a human saying I
just bragging is a woman yes she is
white yeah she's black but she's got
sandals on right she's got a wand she's
the same height gun has no sandals yet
same height is that Adam and Eve they
say all these details which kind of
getting left out in the traditional
version they don't the other thing
always looks like what he does and yeah
this is heavy hit it and this is the
issue the issue is when you make a movie
a lot of the interpretations either get
whittled off or they get more uniform
you know because you can't interpret too
much from the movie now you can or you
can I the movie and say well you know
that's not literal they just took the
literal reading of the biomass but they
found it but that's what physics is
physics is literal only literal so if
you're not gonna explain it literally
well then you're not doing physics yeah
okay anyways we'll continue on tomorrow
same time same station we might change
the subject but this is an interesting
subject all I want to leave you was that
last notion you do need to clarify words
you need to identify words you need to
explain words you need to define words
before you get into a debate about
physics or science or whatever because
there's gonna be we're not gonna be
using movies if we're gonna do the next
best thing which is words now we gotta
be really precise especially in that
case but if you know physics is done
with objects but if you're just gonna do
concepts you know you're just gonna use
words then hopefully you define them
very precisely so that people don't have
you know ambiguous interpretations of
them anyway so I'll leave you with that
thought and we'll see you tomorrow same
time same station see you then bye bye